tonight's is the big debate fetterman
versus Dr Oz and I know it's a
Pennsylvania thing but we have to watch
it we do you know we were talking about
it before the show and we're like a lot
of people are going to want to watch
this debate we got to comment on it the
other day was the DeSantis debate but
that was an hour before our show went
live the thing is fetterman cannot
understand words that are said to him so
he has to use a special device and and
it's sad you know but this a lot of
people expect is going to be a disaster
of of a debate because he has to use
this device to see the questions that
the moderators will ask and then see
what Dr Oz says in real time how much
you want to bet Dr Oz tries to say like
how much wood could a woodchuck could
chuck wood so that the machine jumbles
it and fetterman's like I mean not
literally the woodchuck thing but if if
Dr Oz starts peeking too quickly or uses
obscure small words followed by larger
words and it mashes them together
fetterman's gonna I don't know what you
said I'm sorry and it's and he's gonna
stumble so
we're gonna see what he has to offer the
big thing is that they're within two
points of each other and considering the
margin of error it effectively means Oz
is going to win in Pennsylvania if
nothing changes so fetterman is
desperate so we're gonna watch some of
that debate we'll see how it goes if
it's if it's stupid and pointless maybe
we'll just excuse me talk about
something else we got a bunch of other
stories too we got in Arizona this is
getting crazy they're upping security at
ballot boxes because uh the Dropbox is
because armed men were seen now the
Democrats are suing this is a path
towards dangerous escalation plus we got
Adidas dropping Kanye West's shoes Kanye
West one of the Lex Friedman podcast
we'll talk about all that things are
getting particularly interesting but
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started we have an awesome new sponsor
and it is established titles.com
head over to established titles.com
timpool if you would like to be a lord
or Lady of Scotland I have this very
cool Proclamation that was sent to me I
guess this means that I'm actually a
lord of Scotland I don't know what that
means for politics here in the United
States but uh it's cool it's basically
you're buying a square foot of land let
me let me read for you what we got here
established titles allows you to gain
the title of Lord or lady and officially
included on your credit card plane
tickets dating profiles and more wow
it's a Project based on historic
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as Lords and Ladies their
title packs give you at least one square
foot of dedicated land with a unique
plot Number and on a private estate in
edelston Scotland an official
certificate with the crest so I'm a lord
now I think does that put me above count
dankula I think I think does that or do
counts out rank Lord it counts are Lords
too I could be wrong about that yeah
dukes and counts I'm above count dankula
now that's it's official because I got
this to add to that they're also a fun
and novel way to preserve the natural
Woodlands of Scotland while helping
Global reforestation efforts they do
this by planting a tree with every order
and work with global Charities like one
tree planted in trees to the future is
super cool the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my link
will effectively be next to my plot
within a few minutes of walking distance
it makes for an amazing last minute gift
established titles is running a massive
early Black Friday sale right now and if
you use the code Temple you get an
additional 10 off go to established
titles.com timpool to get your gifts now
and help support the channel it's really
cool I got we have this little thing
we'll hang it up in here because it's a
proclamation and I think it absolves me
of any political responsibilities
because I'm a lord in Scotland so there
you go so again establish titles.com
timpool but also head over to
timcast.com become a member we have that
awesome members only show coming up for
you at 11 p.m uncensored Not So Family
friend friendly and of course as a
member you're helping support our
journalists which is greatly needed and
very important the debate's getting
started soon so let's just go quick
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this and more is Andrew cluster you want
to grab your microphone and headphones
yeah sorry what happened so uh so who
are you what do you do it's it's it's
you got to flip it upside down you got
to flip it you're no no no no no no you
have it on I have it on no no no
there you go sorry about that all right
now now I'm a neophy now who are you hi
I'm you gotta get it pretty close yeah
sure uh I'm Andrew Closter I'm a lawyer
with I have a C3 called Personnel policy
operations I'm DC based I was in the
Trump White House and a number of
agencies so I've been around on the
conservative side of public policy for
over a decade now and gone strong so
glad to be here thanks for having me
right on you are unprepared I'm just
joking messing with you my name is
of we are change.org uh unpopular
opinion no politician is coming to save
you and this is why I wore my if you
trust the uh the government you don't
know history shirt if you like it you
could get it on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com because you
do I'm here thanks for having me I've
returned from across the Great Divide to
send my love to all of you hello welcome
back I'm Ian Crossland good to be here
Andrew good to meet you man good to meet
you too Serge what's happening Brother
hey Ian how are you guys doing surge.com
again you know where to find me let's
pull the debate the debate's starting
here we go
serve Pennsylvania let me fix the audio
yeah man that spent more than 20 million
dollars what's going on
nothing aliens I'm
so having to talk about something called
what's with the audio
that if he's on TV that's not us
that's definitely them it's not us at
all on his TV show because we have
perfect feet and I'm listening to this
oh no dude our record that's his voice
and he's also lying probably during yes
what is going on with us talk about the
elephant in the room I had a stroke he's
never let me forget that
and I might miss some words during this
debate two words together but it knocked
me down while coming back wow yeah I'm
in the pain it's all about to me I'm in
the board this is definitely them oh I
know yeah
that needs to get back up and fighting
for all forgotten communities
Pennsylvania yeah
that needs to keep back up yo they're
audience their audio is all screwed up a
businessman and television personality
but this is your first run for elections
what qualifies you to be a U.S senator
from Pennsylvania you sound like aliens
60 seconds I'm running for the U.S
Senate because Washington keeps getting
it wrong with existing even the playing
field
disability balance all the things that
you want to see because you've been
telling them what's up with the audio is
so busted by doing that we can bring
this together in a way that has not been
done yo are they throwing it for
fettermen I don't know it could be many
things there's a lot of things in this
chain going up here but I would not be
surprised if they're tanking the audio
on purpose because of this that would be
wild someone yeah
tell me that WPXI this is like a local
news station just all of a sudden they
do audio every day for hours and they
can't get the audio right now trying to
get as many murderers let's try and find
a better one
look at that there's nothing I felt bad
about rubbing the headphones but yeah no
you're right they're fine they're just
not too bad
what a waste of our time oh no they want
us to watch ads now all right Goya
please fix the audio I'm a big fan of
beans
uh raising our taxes
oh my God what if they are robots and
not humans
or or they live aliens all right all
right can someone try and find a
different stream I guess I'm looking
right now I'm I can't I'm looking it up
on on YouTube and nothing really even
comes up what about the new sites
website next star Emerson College the
economy inflation are the biggest
concerns for voters what is up with this
as the top issue beginning with w uh
WPXI President Biden
spending for the
I wonder if it's if you go on their
website yeah there you go wait no people
are saying the audio is good for them in
the chat
from the from that feed but for us it
sounds like so Alias it's it's weird no
people people were saying in the chat on
their feed please fix the audio and
they're laughing saying it's all jacked
up no it's on their main website on the
top left corner some people are saying
the audio is fine I can't I'll tell you
they have four percent there we go I've
traveled over the Commonwealth and
spoken to countless people how do I make
it bigger than the county fair who told
me
that she wanted to provide for yeah
that you couldn't afford it we'll take
it that's a big problem if we've got
four percent waste and
fraudible take care of that John
fetterman's however responds continually
is to raise taxes taxes as mayor he
tried to raise taxes there's a
lieutenant governor 46 that's a big tax
rate he supported Joe Biden's recent tax
rate increase and he's done that without
paying his own taxes 67 times I'll say
that again he hasn't paid his own taxes
67 times but he's raising mine in yours
those are radical positions they're
extreme they're out of touch with the
values of pennsylvanians and I can make
the difficult decisions as you do in the
operating room as a surgeon I'll make
them cutting our budget as well debates
where they insult each other
in pain from the high inflation rate Mr
fetterman I will allow a 15 second
rebuttal he has specifically said you
have not paid your taxes that's a good
thing I like Letterman because of that
fetterman yes there we go man you got my
vote now pause rule of course he's lying
it was helping two students 17 years ago
to help them you know buy their own
homes they they didn't pay the bills and
it got her paid and it's it's never been
an issue on the campaign before this is
dark it was all about non-profit
all right thank you Mr fetterman
continuing with you your opponent has
criticized Democratic spending as you
heard has providing Administration
overspent and if so where do you think
spending should be cut you have 60
Seconds
no here's something about information
here right now that's what we need to
fight about inflation you know right now
because it's a tax on Working Families
you know and Dr Oz can't possibly
understand what that is like you know he
has 10 gigantic Mansions you know he you
know we must push back against corporate
greed you know we must make sure that
we're also pushing back against price
gouging as well too you know we also be
able to make more in Pennsylvania
America when he had a choice to this is
this is wrong merchandise the odds label
is on he made it all in China you know
who can you believe that can fight
against inflation and pushing back
against corporate greed or somebody that
has chosen working in China
versus over
American workers all right I will allow
a 15 second rebuttal to his comments
that you have been making things in
China
people of Pennsylvania as a doctor I
listened to their ideas I don't want to
talk about them when John fetterman
brings up houses the irony is he didn't
pay for his own house he got it for a
dollar from his sister and he hasn't
been able to earn a living on his own
he's lived off his parents so it doesn't
it's not a topic that we should be
debating on the stage we should be
talking about crime and inflation the
issues that are hurting pennsylvanians
that they're talking about at their
kitchen table fetterman probably did
that not to pay taxes yeah he got that's
right that's why is Dr Oz being like pay
more taxes from a dollar we have to
continue on we'll continue on with the
question a follow-up question to you Mr
Oz this one is just for you you tweeted
in August that you will never stop
fighting to lower gas prices for
pennsylvanians does that include
supporting a suspension of the federal
gas tax you have 30 seconds I'm
supportive of reducing taxes but we want
to be thoughtful about the long-term
game plan to get gas taxes down and
frankly all energy prices down I have
gone around the Commonwealth I've
witnessed people say I'm not going on
vacation this year because I can't
afford to pay to take my trailer to the
campground they can't even get there
what we have to do is ensure that we
don't have increased inflation and the
best way to do that is reduce gas prices
John fetterman has gone after the energy
industry called it a stain on
Pennsylvania and argued we have to ban
fracking that is it disconnected from
Pennsylvania thank you thank you Mr Oz
we will get to the issue of fracking
later on in this discussion but meantime
turning back to you Mr fetterman for a
follow-up
in an op-ed for the Wilkes-Barre Times
Leader you wrote quote it is time we
crack down on the big price gouging
corporations that are making record
profits while jacking up prices for all
of us how do you plan to do this sir you
mentioned price going after price
gouging corporations how do you plan to
do this you have 30 seconds yeah yeah
exactly we have to keep pushing back on
that and he would never make that choice
to fight for uh for it for uh Amer
families here in Pennsylvania you know
he has never met an air an oil company
that he doesn't swipe right about you
know what he has never been able to
stand up for Working Families all across
Pennsylvania you know we must push back
inflation has hurt Americans and
Pennsylvania's families and it has given
the oil companies record profits all
right thank you Mr federal return to the
next issue
we just call it I'm open to that we call
it it's going to be a lot more of this
watching an hour of that no we can't do
it we can't do it too much I'm sorry
everybody level currently sits it's
seven dollars 25 cents an hour no we're
just gonna we're just gonna have to
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna John
fetterman's in recovery from a stroke
that should be the topic of it that
should be the main topic of the debate I
mean it's a doctor and a guy that's
recovering from a stroke on stage how
can they not be talking about that
that's so important it's embarrassing
that last sentence I'm I'm I'm actually
starting to feel sad yeah watching this
like I feel really bad I'm like come on
man I don't want to make a spectacle out
of the guy but he's doing it to himself
by running for for office he's basically
like what are we supposed to do we have
to point out the inadequacies yo we we
had planned on on watching that debate
I'm sorry if you guys wanted to I
figured that most people would probably
want to see it considering it's a it's a
prominent Senate race it's very close we
have here if we can pull this up the 538
polling that fetterman's up 2.3 points
but considering the huge error in
polling that it's it's probably going to
swing towards us so we figured this
would be important I didn't think it was
going to be that bad yeah that was
painful too I I I'm I really did not
think it was going to be that bad I
wasn't I was uncomfortable I was like I
I didn't fuse because how do you comment
on that you know I'm not making fun of
that guy you can't make fun of someone
like that in that situation yeah but you
do have to call out you know I I think
there's a bigger story to this we talked
about this a couple days ago
specifically about the big powers and
the big interests pushing individuals
because there was a lot of powerful
individuals that invested into him and I
could see him being pushed and pushed by
those special interests to be on stage
when clearly he he shouldn't be you know
I thought Biden also was pushed although
I don't have evidence do you guys have
any evidence Obama said to Biden you
don't have to do this and his wife
apparently he walked off and got lost
today at the White House and there's a
mean post posted about this specifically
being like you know he has no people
that love him because if he did they
would make sure he wouldn't be working
the most stressful job at his old age uh
when clearly he's having a lot of
problems this is what I think you know
when we talk about
the fall of Empire the end of the
country or the cultural collapse or
whatever it is you want to call it it's
not it's not some tyrannical psychopath
the way the left screams about fascism
it is it is fetterman it is Biden yeah I
gotta say it again like we were talking
about it uh we were downstairs you know
we're in the green room we're getting
ready before the show playing pool and
stuff and I'm like you know uh Kellen
who does production stuff for us was
like oh hey the debate's tonight and I'm
like oh we definitely got to watch that
it's gonna be a big one right we would
have watched the DeSantis one it
probably would have been bigger and then
I'm and then I'm you know Luke was like
I don't know and I said look fetterman's
gonna be using this special device it's
going to get interesting
that was brutal yeah that was that was
that was way way worse it was on you
couldn't even listen to it you can't
even listen to it there's no point I
don't know man maybe maybe we need to
make people listen to it but I'm sure I
assume most people who watch this
already know but I'm glad I'm glad in a
sense they are doing the debate because
as bad as it is for fetterman
there are a lot of people who need to
watch that
they need to watch that and be like okay
this is not a meme it's not a joke
the dude could not talk or understand I
don't even know what the last sent the
last thing he responded to about uh uh
what was I don't even know what he was
saying that he didn't know a Heir he
could oil uh he would swipe right on and
I'm like like Tinder I guess he's saying
like if it was a Tinder and uh swiping
right on the oil companies but then he
said America when he meant Pennsylvania
and it was so they prepared him he had
some canned lines but I mean that's
brutal and there are thousands of people
in Pennsylvania what do they think they
have nothing else to watch right now you
know I'm sure they get a lot of other
stuff and this is the beginning they're
gonna watch it I mean debates are tough
they're they're really difficult for you
know your mind to process a lot of
information very quickly there's a lot
of questions there's a lot of things you
need to really hone in on and to be at
your Peak mental ability in order to to
proceed this could be interfering in his
Rehabilitation this could be uh
interfering in in healing some some
people want us to keep it running I
guess we can press one if you want us to
keep us running press two if you don't
want us people are saying watch it yeah
I'm sorry dude like I'm I'm getting
really sad yo like fetterman is a
personable guy right he he he he comes
off like a regular guy and I don't I
don't have any animosity where the guy I
think he's got bad policies but watching
this is like I've been in the room you
know conversation is happening it kind
of reminds me of like watching a dude
who was like I want a great baseball
player who got in a car accident
him hobbling on the field and everyone
clapping being like go for it go for it
and then he falls over and falls on the
ground and everyone's just what I'm like
bro come on there's more ones than twos
but there's also a lot of twos federally
manipulated I just think we have to
watch it you have to follow it
I think people want us to play it we're
gonna play it would force it to be
subsidized taxpayers across the country
no matter what their personal beliefs
are that's radical that's extreme that
is out of touch the average voter in
Pennsylvania believes appropriate now
ironically John fedem has been running
ads on this topic dishonest ads I need
to correct the record they were so bad
they got pulled off television stations
I've got they've been on this station he
was running dishonest ads that I had
pulled off I haven't had a single ad
pulled down my ads tell the truth John
fedmans are a fiction of his imagination
all right I'm going to let Mr fetterman
respond specifically about the ads being
pulled off the air and then we will
return to you Mr Oz Mr fetterman yeah I
want to look into the face of every
woman in Pennsylvania you know if you
believe that the choice of your
reproductive Freedom belongs with Dr Oz
then you have a choice but if you
believe that the choice for abortion
belongs between you and your doctor
that's what I fight for Roe v Wade for
me is should be the law he celebrated
when Roe v Wade went down and my
campaign would fight for Roe v Wade and
if given the opportunity to codify it
into law
should be something that is left up to
the States now Republican senator
Lindsey Graham has introduced a federal
Bill to ban abortion after 15 weeks I
know that you've been asked about this
question before if the vote were held
today you were elected Senator you're on
the senate floor the clerk calls you
there's a roll call vote are you a yay
or a nay how would you vote on the
Lindsey Graham bill you have 30 seconds
Lisa I don't even need 30 seconds I'll
give you a bigger answer I am not going
to support Federal Federal rules that
block the ability of states to do what
they wish to do the abortion decision
should be left up the states and
specifically when John Federman was with
Doug mostrion
you'll have your turn John one moment Mr
fetterman continue I've been very clear
on my desire as a position not to
interfere with how States decide so when
John purposely knowingly misrepresents
that women he scares them he's purposely
trying to alarm them and the
fear-mongering isn't working running
tens of millions of dollars of ads
claiming that I'm against all abortions
when he knows that's not right claiming
that I'm going to be strict with
Pennsylvania but he knows that's not
honest I can't be any clearer that I've
been on the stage today John fedema if
you just hear that one story today I'd
be really happy but I know you're not
going to because you're going to go
right back to telling the fables that
you believe Mr Oz I want a 15 second
clarification you are saying that you
would leave it up to the states of the
federal government does not have a role
here so are you saying you would not
vote for the Lindsey Graham Bill any
bill that violates what I said which is
the federal government interfering with
the state Rule and abortion I would vote
against what I feel strongly about is
that women in Pennsylvania understand
what I'm saying and not believe that
someone who's taking an extreme position
like John Federman represents them
because most women do not believe that
we should at a federal level codify 38
weeks of uh permission to have an
abortion and have taxpayers pay for it
so yes or no on the Lindsey Graham I
think I've answered just barrier clearly
three times okay all right thank you
mister attorney yeah
do you support any limits on when a
woman can have an abortion please
explain it 60 seconds two different
monitors there's a support I support on
Roe v Wade that was the plan for 50
years he celebrated when it fell down
and I would fight to re-establish on Roe
v wait that's what I run on that's what
I believe and I've always believed that
the choice believes women and their
doctors and he believes that the choice
should be with him or republican
legislators all across this nation I do
respect I'm sorry I must correct that
once again he's misrepresented what I've
said but he also said something very
dishonest on this debate stage he said
very specifically in his primary debate
when he was still debating that he would
support 38 weeks of uh mandated Rules by
the federal government that would
prevent any state from blocking it so
that's not roles that's not true I
support Roe v Wade that's the simple
John you just said specifically you
would support a federal 38 weeks thank
you thank you I think it's important
that John at least acknowledged that
he's not honest here because you said we
must continue on Mr fetterman turning to
you we have a follow-up question would
you support allocating federal funds to
transport women who live in states where
abortion is banned to states where they
can get one and why 30 seconds
I would I would because I believe
abortion rights is a universal right for
all women in America I believe that it I
believe abortion is health care and I
believe that that is a choice that
belongs with each woman and their doctor
all right thank you Mr Mr fetterman
turning to the next issue Dennis Thank
you Lisa let's turn to what has become
one of the key themes of this race
Fitness to serve no no no individual
questions there will be no rebuttals
allowed Mr fetterman we begin with you
you suffered as you mentioned a moment
ago a stroke four days before the May
primary last week you released this note
from your doctor saying you can work
full Duty in public office but you have
not released your detailed medical
records the doctor is a donor to his
campaign by the way Mr fetterman will
you pledge tonight to release those
records in the interest of transparency
you have 60 seconds uh three for
transparency is about showing up I'm
here today to have a debate I have you
know speeches in front of 3 000 people
in Montgomery County you know all across
Pennsylvania big big crowds you know I
believe if my doctor believes that I'm
fit to serve and and that's what I
believe is appropriate and now with two
weeks before the election you know I
have run the campaign and I've been very
transparent about being very open about
the fact where I use captioning and I
believe that again my doctors the real
doctors that I believe and they all
believe that I'm ready to be served oh I
didn't hear you say you're ready to be
sure full medical records why not you
have 30 seconds
now uh yeah again my Dr L believes that
I'm fit to be serving and that's what I
believe is where I'm standing okay Mr
fetterman thank you Mr Oz you have built
a lucrative career around medicine but
you've been criticized even by some
fellow Physicians for promoting quote
unproven ill-advised and at times
potentially dangerous treatments what is
your response to that you have 60
seconds what are the great blessings of
traveling around Pennsylvania is you run
into people who had watched the show
they thank me very much for giving them
life-saving advice on chronic issues
like high blood pressure or dealing with
their anxiety the show did very well
because it provided high quality
information that empowered people which
was I was exactly what I want to do when
I'm a senator give people the power let
them make decisions for their well-being
now John fetterman's approach to health
is a very dangerous one he believes we
should socialize medicine he embraced
this with Bernie Sanders who endorsed
the two candidates call themselves The
two most Progressive people in America
when you have socialized medicine
it's a disaster and it puts people at
risk so I don't believe we should allow
I wonder if they're asking them about
the transition of kids that he was
promoting 10 years ago and radical
positions like the ones taken away too
extreme to serve if we're going to bring
balance to Washington you got to bring
people who understand the ramifications
even Joe Biden
call John federman's idea I'll quote him
Preposterous uh Mr fetterman I'm going
to let you respond in just a minute but
I have a follow-up for you first Mr Oz
did you or your company make a profit
from promoting those products you have
30 seconds I never sold weight loss
products as as described in those
commercials it's a it's a television
show like this is a television show so
people can run commercials on the show
that's not the question that's a
perfectly appropriate and very
transparent process I ruffled a lot of
feathers on my show because I told
people the truth and I'm proud of that
and I'll do the exact same thing as a
U.S senator but the good but but there's
there's there's no way to defend what
John fetterman has done with socialized
medicine that is a radical departure
from what we in America the relationship
between you John you'll have your turn
John
the doctor and a patient and that's uh
shut up patience to do thank you Mr
fetterman he accused you of socialized
medicine supporting socialized medicine
what is your response again again it's
the Oz rule he's on TV and he's lying
I've never so I never supported any of
that thing you know he keeps talking
about Bernie Bernie Sanders you know
three years three years ago he was on
his show and he hugged him and he said I
love this guy you know what why don't
you pretend that you you live in Vermont
instead of Pennsylvania and right
against Bernie Sanders because all you
can do is talk about Bernie Sanders
because my truth is is that Healthcare
is a basic fundamental right and I
believe in expanding that and I believe
about supporting fighting for Health
Care the kind of Health Care that saved
my life
explicitly supported social distance
we are going to move on to the next
topic and this has come up earlier and
that is the issue of fracking
Pennsylvania only Trails Texas in terms
of natural gas production both of you
have taken shifting positions on the
issue of fracking Mr Oz we begin with
you
you wrote a column in 2014 calling for
no fracking pending health study results
but in a video posted on social media in
March you said quote natural gas
guarantees high-paying skill jobs right
here in Pennsylvania so back off Biden
give us freedom to Frack Mr Oz please
explain that changing position 60
seconds I've been very consistent
fracking has been demonstrated it's a
very old technology to be safe it is a
Lifeline for this Commonwealth to be
able to build wealth similar to what
they've been able to achieve in other
states for that reason I strongly
support fracking drilling the piping of
that natural gas in fact I built a
facility even in Philadelphia so we can
export it to our allies and help them
the ones that are struggling now in
eastern and western Europe because of
the Ukrainian War John Federman calls
fracking a stain on Pennsylvania he says
that he was signed a moratorium to ban
its continued use he's against pipelines
he voted him are supported the vote
against the Keystone Pipeline that ended
up shutting it down he supports Biden's
desire to ban fracking on public lands
which are our lands all of our lands
together this is a extreme position on
energy if we unleashed our energy here
in Pennsylvania it would help everybody
why John Federman is so rigidly stuck on
fighting about against energy companies
is stunning to me because it's the jobs
I want tens of thousands of high-paying
jobs to help Pennsylvania thank you Mr
Osmond Oz rule Mr fetterman I absolutely
support fracking in fact I live across
the street from a steel mill and they
were going to frac to create their own
energy in order to make them more
competitive and I support that living
closer to anybody else in Pennsylvania
for fracking to myself I believe that we
need independence with energy and I
believe I've walked that line my entire
career I believe Democrats Mr fetterman
I do have a specific question which you
can continue on this topic but you have
made two conflicting statements
regarding tracking in a 2018 interview
you said quote I don't support fracking
at all I never have but earlier this
month you told an interviewer quote I
support fracking I support the energy
Independence that we should have here in
the United States so Mr fetterman please
explain your changing position 67 good
question and good job by her I've I've
always supported fracking and I always
want it Independence our energy is is
critical and we can't be held you know
you know Ransom to somebody like Russia
you know I've always believed that
energy Independence is critical and I've
always believed that and I do support
fracking I've never taken any money from
their their their industry but I support
how critical it is that we produce our
own energy and create energy
Independence I must correct the record
just a second Mr Oz I do want to clarify
something you're saying tonight that you
support fracking that you've all always
supported fracking but there is that
2018 interview that you said quote I
don't support fracking at all so how do
you square the two good job it's it's
truth
I lived experience oh I I do support
fracking and I love oh my man I don't
love fracking I support fracking I
understand and I do support fracking
whoa thank you Mr fetterman oh sorry
Lisa it's not just because
we have to move on but we have to get
the fundamentals of the truth out here
we have over and over again took
positions against energy we have a lot
of topics you will have a chance to have
that you may want one comment then the
energy Industries
we want to now turn to Public Safety Mr
Federer oh man Republicans have called
you dangerously soft on crime the
Pennsylvania State Troopers Association
has endorsed Democrat Josh Shapiro for
governor but in this race it endorsed
your Republican opponent Mr Oz what is
your response to those endorsements and
what is your response to accusations
that you are quote dangerously soft on
crime you have 60
gun violence and that's exactly what I
did in working with the police and
working with our community I would say I
was able to stop gun violence for five
and a half years as mayor ever
accomplished before or since my time as
as mayor because I'm the only person on
this stage right now that has con it can
is successful about pushing back against
gun violence and being the community
more safe you know all is the community
more safe
in the last 24 hours he has no
experience he has never made any attempt
to try to address crime during his
entire career except showing up this is
his photo ops here in Philadelphia he
voted for a convicted murderers to be
released from jail are we supposed to
translate he's from Braddock the small
town he represented endorsed me they
supported me because what he's saying is
not true violence skyrocketed and
Braddock I mean the town wasn't in good
shape when John got there it got worse
when he was there people kept leaving so
of course you're going to have uh you
know all kinds of bear aberrations but
John the city was dangerous under your
leadership and that's right Mr Oz this
past summer Congress passed the first
gun control bill in decades that would
not have happened without the support of
the man you are running to replace Pat
Toomey how would you have voted on that
bill
toomey's Legacy as being one of the lead
republicans in Congress on pushing for
gun reforms you have 60 seconds
I have been supported by Pat Toomey I've
enjoyed working with him I think he's
done a wonderful job there are parts of
that bill that I like a lot for example
I like the fact that their background
checks that are being strengthened now
so we can make sure that people who
should not have guns don't get guns I
also like the fact that there was a lot
of money invested for mental health
which is an important part of the
equation I've been to Philadelphia I've
done prayer vigils with black clergy
leaders who are desperately trying to
save the people in their Community half
the murders in Philadelphia committed by
people under 18 we have got to get
Mental Health Services to these people
and it's not happening now but part of
the problem is that we have taken away
the ability of police to do their job
and that's on John fetterman because
John Federman has taken such a harsh
position against them he's undermined
them at every level taking away some of
their funding he's pushed for krasner
who he admires tremendously he's spoken
highly of him just this week he's taken
his policies to a new extreme he argued
that people should be let out of jail
without any Bill no matter what they did
to get in there he argued to release
one-third of all prisoners one-third of
all prisoners out of touch quickly 15
seconds would you have voted for that to
me I bet he's a Scottish Lord I would
have tried to improve that bill there
are things that I think most of us
appreciate I wasn't there at the time so
I can't speak to what was possible but I
do know there are parts of that bill
that do make sense and the ones I
described should be followed let's see
how it works out okay thank you I don't
agree with them
unconstitutional it has been a problem
in the United States for decades but it
is now spiking U.S Customs and Border
Protection just released numbers from
fiscal year 2022 they show more than 2.7
million total enforcement actions in the
U.S that is the most ever Mr Oz
beginning with you Republican governors
in the South have been sending migrants
to democratic run cities and states
without a plan or without any
coordination it is certainly gaining a
lot of attention but good is it an
effective way to deal with the influx of
migrants you have 60 Seconds Lisa we
have a catastrophe at the border and we
should not have Sanctuary cities as John
fetterman has tried to introduce but
I've been into the parts of Philadelphia
and Allentown and reading where we have
large Latino populations I understand
the challenges of the of the Border my
father was an immigrant my mother were
immigrants you know I understand what
legal immigration offers us but the
completely porous open nature of our
border which John Federman supports has
created a humanitarian crisis with
cartels profiting with human trafficking
operations
in China and bring that into our country
and it's making every state a border
state Pennsylvania is already a border
state because we're top three in the
country and Fentanyl overdoses
I don't meet multiple people who say
their personal lives destroyed because
of fentanyl overdoses not only wants an
open border that's what I'm saying like
this is three cities but he wants to
legalize hard drugs in America including
narcotics I think that's warmed up
though I think
touch with everybody that radical
position was tried in Oregon which he
endorsed 50 homicide increase rate oh
one moment I will give a 15 second
rebuttal yeah that that is again uh his
rule that is just not true uh you know
you know here is his family's company
was it was levied the largest fine for
immigration High immigration of
immigrate uh and I think you should sit
this one out about in terms of what uh
what did it even just say how long it
was a stroke
the southern border border is secure yet
we are seeing an unprecedented number of
migrants Crossing is the border secure
and if not what would you do to fix what
both parties are calling a crisis you
have 60 seconds Mr fetterman
you know I believe that I believe that a
secure border is can be compatible with
compassion I believe we need a
comprehensive and bipartisan solution
for immigration that's what I believe I
don't ever recall in the Statue of
Liberty did they say you know you know
take our entire huddle masses and put
them on a bus and use cheap political
stunts about them I believe we have to
develop a comprehensive and bicartisan
solution bicartisan to address or issue
for immigration here and the memes
tomorrow everything
this is sick what do you believe is the
greatest foreign threat to the United
States of America you have 60 seconds Dr
Oz
if he says I believe I I believe you
know is is right now is is China I
believe China is not our friend and I
believe that we can't be able to push
back and we need to stand against China
and I believe that Dr Oz has chosen to
take uh manufacture all of his
merchandise on his name on it in China
which one of us on this stage is going
to stand up against and stand firm
against China you know and I believe
that's our single biggest issue right
now to make sure that we address China
and make sure that we know that it's not
our friend Mr Ross what do you believe
is the greatest foreign threat to the
United States of America you have 60
seconds the fact that our country is not
projecting strength take for example
what we're doing with Iran in order to
try to get them to give us a little oil
so we can deal with the catastrophe that
Russia has caused we have gone to them
and tried to sign a deal that would
allow them once again to have the
nuclear power to blow up Israel which
they promised they would do John
fetterman supports that deal it doesn't
make any sense for America to treat our
enemies better than our allies we have
the message with our strong voice and
the energy we have in our country that
we have control over our future and the
best way for America to establish its
dominance is to unleash the energy here
in Pennsylvania and across the country
by not doing that not only do we cause
all kinds of problems with local jobs
and inflation but we're destroying our
ability to remain energy dominant and
we're not able to become allies like we
should be for countries like European
nations which are going to struggle
their with their Coldest Winter Ever
it's the best way to punch puts me back
and to teach China lesson is American
Energy to reign supreme and John
fetterman doesn't like American Energy
and they are scared of him they know
they can't trust them they keep calling
him Mr Mr Oz but he's a doctor he's
literally a doctor in our recent next
time
Joe Biden and Donald Trump in 2012. oh
look at that Trump wins the a
statistical tie in Pennsylvania 46 of
people said they would vote for former
president Trump 45 percent for President
Biden Mr Oz would you support 2024 run
and why 60 seconds where the Republican
Party puts up and I have reached out
across the aisle on my campaign because
I want to bring balance to Washington
and I've tried to work with Democrats
and Republicans and people in the middle
people unsure and people who forgotten
people who got angry with where their
party was headed I want to bring us
together to make this country do what
it's always been able to do unify not
divide and address the problems as a
surgeon because in the or that's what I
do I just fix the big problem in Front
of Me John fetterman however cannot go
to Washington and work with the other
side because he doesn't even get along
with his own side he criticism for not
spending enough money and not settling
up close enough to Bernie Sanders he
says he won't work with Joe manchin he
said if you vote if you like Joe manchin
don't vote for me so if you're picking
fights with your own party you're not
going to be able to reach across the
aisle to the other side his extreme
positions have made it untenable for
Republican law Acres we need to send
someone to Washington who understands
the importance of balance sensible
decision making and in common sense
approach to the challenges that we all
face that's not John fetterman Mr Oz
he has endorsed you why won't you fully
commit to supporting him in 2024. oh I
do I would support Donald Trump if he
decided to run for president all right
but this is bigger than one candidate
this is a much bigger story about how we
are going to build a bigger tent to let
more Americans feel safe are you
concerned about the ongoing legal
investigations involving the former
president 32nd sir I haven't followed
them very carefully I've been
campaigning pretty aggressively they'll
work themselves out I have tremendous
confidence in the American legal system
and I believe law and order will Reigns
supreme but speaking about that topic
there's one person on this stage who's
broken the law We Believe John fetterman
took a shotgun chase state
and put the gun apparently according to
that man to his chest John you weren't
pulled over by the police they let you
go you were the mayor at the time why
haven't you apologized to that unarmed
innocent black man who you put a shotgun
to his chest whoa a 30-second response
to that Mr fetterman specifically what
he was saying referring to the incident
and Braddock I I made the opportunity to
defend my community as the chief law
enforcement officer there everybody in
Braddock an overwhelming majority uh
community of of black uh Community all
understood what happened you know they
they understood what happened and
everybody agreed that and nobody
believes that it was anything about me
making a split second decision to to
defend our community as well why not
apologize uh Mr Oz please we are still
with Mr fetterman turning to you right
now you support a Biden run do you
support a Biden run in 2024 why in 60
Seconds
uh that's honestly it's up to his choice
whether he you know and if he does
choose to run I would absolutely support
him but ultimately that's ultimately
only his choice all right thank you Mr
fetterman a follow-up question on this
our next star poll shows 51 of
Pennsylvania voters disapprove of the
president's job performance you have
publicly supported many of his policy
positions are there any that you
disagree with 30 seconds that's good
who can type this fast does not compute
no I just believe he needs to do more
about supporting uh and fighting about
in inflation uh and I I do believe he
can do more about that but uh at the end
of the day I think Joe Biden is a good
good family man and I believe he stands
for the union way of life and I believe
that employment unemployment is already
down to the lowest level in the last 50
years
turn now gentlemen to the issue of
Social Security it is only fully funded
through 2013. many Americans actually
buy to disagree with that statement
their full benefit or have to accept
cuts to their benefits Mr fetterman how
are you going to make sure it is there
for them you have 60 seconds
we need to make sure that Dr Oz and the
Republicans believed in cutting Medicare
and Social Security and I believe that
they've got to be reading you have to
support
Social Security
I would support and stand and to support
security uh sounds like a real security
okay thank you Mr Roz same question to
you how are you going to make sure that
Social Security is available for future
Americans you have 60 seconds we made a
deal with the wonderful seniors of our
nation they worked their hearts out they
paid into a program no one's going to
touch it on my watch except to make sure
that it's stronger than it is right now
Social Security Medicare which I know a
lot about as a doctor are the
fundamental uh element of security for
our seniors and they deserve to feel
like their value by our nation John
fetterman again has been running ads and
saying that I'm against those with no
proof I have never said anything
different than what I'm saying to you on
this stage but in an effort to
fear-monger with people who are older
and can be taken advantage of he'll run
these ads John it's reprehensible but
it's also reflective of your approach to
doing these things you haven't shown up
on the campaign Trail you haven't
answered questions from voters not once
on the campaign Trail you haven't
answered questions from media once in
the campaign Trail image you know just
to show off that you could do it and
this is the only debate I could get you
to come to talk to me on and I had to
beg on my knees to get you to come and
if it wasn't for Dennis probably getting
involved I don't think it would have
happened look seniors need to know more
about your radical left positions and I
need to be able to tell them about my
positions that's what democracy is built
on we exchange ideas the voters decide
you have hidden from it Mr Oz I'm going
to let you have 15 seconds in a moment
Mr fetterman but can you give us a
specific example of what you would do to
protect Social Security well for one we
have to make sure that it adequately
increases with the higher inflation
rates that we have so we've got to make
that four percent of wasted money that
right now is in the budget uh redirected
appropriately and one of the first
places that I would use it is Social
Security and Medicare and here's the
reason one of the worst things we can do
to a people is give them bad quality uh
care and so if you have
if you have people who are not going to
see a doctor for example because they
can't afford it they'll get sicker Bad
Medicine means more costs no one
benefits thank you Mr fetterman he said
a few things a moment ago I want to give
you 15 seconds to respond to those
now again I just can't I can't just say
one thing other than that Dr Oz would
not support and he would support cutting
Medicare he would not support it John
why do you say that I've never said that
it's absolutely effect it's a fact you
would have voted against the the
inflation reduction act which has
dropped our prescription drugs and he
doesn't believe okay gentlemen we need
to move on at least
on to the topic of Education the cost of
college tuition is now Out Of Reach for
many many families our question is
what is your plan to bring down the cost
of higher education long term you have
one minute Mr Oz I've worked in academic
medical centers my whole life so I'm in
higher education and I can tell you the
reason the prices have gone up six-fold
in the last 40 years is not because the
education quality is better we've added
extra extra layers of middle middle
level individuals who don't actually
improve the quality education in my
opinion there's a lot of expenses that
now incurred by these institutions and
it's not right for the American people
to be stuck with the bill I would push
them to offer more electronic classes
half the kids don't live on campus
anyway John fetterman's approach however
is not to deal with the unnecessarily
high cost but just to pay it so if you
want to pay students who didn't pay
their loans back basically what John
fetterman and Joe Biden are are arguing
for is for plumbers who didn't go to
college and couldn't for a bunch of
reasons afford it to pay the bills of
lawyers who went to graduate school and
haven't paid their debt back I don't
think that's right for the American
people we want a fair system drop the
cost down by pushing for more value for
the money we're spending and then ensure
there's a high quality education that
lets people make a living when they
graduate all right I will allow a 15
second rebuttal specifically on the
issue of student loan debt which Mr oswa
is referring to Mr fetterman uh again Dr
Oz you know loves free free money when
it's a half a million dollar tax break
on one of his you know homes down in a
ranch in Florida and whether it was a 50
tax break you know about his farm in
Montgomery County so it's about
supporting and helping you know young
earners excuse me young
young uh
young you know students to give them a
break I believe that
that supporting uh all right let me just
ask facility
student loan debt the debt problems
again I I I do absolutely again like a
little blow them up belly it's about
helping Young Learners you know be able
to get a better start you know getting
off in the start of their life and I I
do believe that and I believe a majority
of Americans support that as well too
helping helping young Young Learners all
right Mr fetterman I want to ask you the
same question that I asked Mr Oz and
what is your plan to bring down the cost
of higher education long term you have
one minute
yeah I don't think he he didn't answer
he didn't answer the the question
whatsoever
I believe Charles please give him a
moment no you didn't you didn't you know
I fundamentally believe that every
quality Public University education
should be very affordable in in every
state and I think that needs to be a
significant investment you know to make
sure that anyone be able to afford to go
to get a four degree University degree
you know a year degree or anything State
schools more affordable and that's a
four degree University a significant
investment to make sure and create it
affordable that every family can afford
how exactly Mr fetterman do you propose
doing that to make it more affordable
for a fan for families
now I I just believe I just making it
that much more I just believe I lost too
much and I believe providing the
resources to reduce the tuition to allow
families to be able to afford it all
right we have a follow-up question this
one now is for both of you this is from
news Nation viewer Ann Andrews a
registered nurse from conneautville near
Erie and is a vocational educational
instructor for University and a
practicing registered nurse
if you were elected could you please
tell me what you would be doing for
vocational education in the state of
Pennsylvania as well as our nation
so Mr Oz if elected what would you do
for vocational education you have 30
seconds I've visited vocational schools
I have an answer but John because you
obviously I wasn't clear enough for you
to understand this there's no question
that cutting out the middle levels of
higher education and providing digital
programs would reduce the cost of
Education it's a Concrete set of ideas
that I'd like to move on with regard to
vocational education this is really
important for us to allow our trade
unions to get closerly linked more
closely linked with the vocational
schools I was in a vocational school in
Westmoreland and they have about a
thousand kids they could take two
thousand kids funding those programs is
the smartest way to invest our tax
dollars will turn out twice as many
children who have a job as soon as they
graduate it supports our trade unions
who want those kids in their positions
anyway that makes the whole program
we're watching the Republicans Mr
fetterman if elected what would you do
for vocational education you have 30
seconds again I think it's going to
happen it's just the same way University
four degrees as well too supporting that
and partnering with the the unions and
making sure that vocation training are
as as uh is Affordable and providing the
resources to make sure everyone has the
opportunity going to college isn't the
right choice for it for every person you
know but going to those kind of
emotional schools and you're able to
create a career to wait to excuse me to
Wayne Uh reach a lot of uh High salary
and again supporting to reduce those
costs are critical too all right thank
you gentlemen this race is not saying
anymore this race is costing more than a
quarter of a billion dollars I've called
for the Supreme Court to be expanded
candidates we want to know where you
stand on this Mr fetterman should the
Supreme Court be expanded and if so by
how many justices you have 60 seconds I
I don't believe I've never I don't stand
and I don't believe in that you know I
fundamentally believe that even though I
don't agree with the ideological breakup
of the Supreme Court you know I believe
believe it's not about changing the
rules it's about acknowledging where
we're at much the way the Republicans
want to try to change the Constitution
about how our Supreme Court in
Pennsylvania was going to be done and I
don't support that so I think it's it's
critical that we be consistent and I do
not believe in supporting the Supreme
Court Mr Ross same question to you
should the Supreme Court be expanded if
so by how many justices you have 60
seconds I would never touch the makeup
of the Supreme Court and I would
Advocate to leave it the exact same size
it is but John fetterman's radical
positions have spilled over into what he
would do in Washington one of the first
things he has said and he came back to
the campaign Trail is that he wanted to
bust the filibuster which means removing
the the brakes on the Senate
overreacting that's true that is that is
true but if you do that then you would
free up the Democrats in the Senate
without getting the normal amount of
votes to actually expand the Supreme
Court add more states do things that are
detrimental to the well-being of the
country so I think and your first day
back arguing that we should get rid of
the filibuster is a dangerously radical
move that would hurt Washington it's not
in our nation's best interest yeah it
would lead to a civil war no joke thank
you both very much
all right at this time we are ready for
our closing statements you each have 90
seconds
to vote for you on Election Day Mr
fetterman you are first 90 seconds
once again I would just like to say that
I my campaign is all about fighting for
anyone in Pennsylvania that ever got
knocked down that had to get back up
again you know I'm also fighting for any
forgotten Community all across
Pennsylvania's they ever got knocked
down it had to be made to get back up
you know I've made my entire career
dedicating to those kinds of Pursuits I
started as a GED instructor back in in
Braddock over 20 years ago because I
believe it's about serving Pennsylvania
not about using Pennsylvania for uh
their own and interests as well to me
careers are revealed
uh by your real underlying values and my
values have always been about fighting
for forgotten communities all across
Pennsylvania all right thank you Mr
fetterman Mr Oz your final thoughts 90
seconds I love traveling four corners of
the beautiful Commonwealth and I've
heard your problems I'm a surgeon doctor
I listen to what you say and I'm trying
to help address them today I've talked
to seniors worried their Social Security
checks wouldn't go far enough with the
Raging inflation
I've talked to couples when I make their
first down payment on a new house and
they can't afford it anymore because of
interest rates I've talked to families
you want to cut Social Security Mr
fetterman it's his turn for his closing
I've talked to families worried about
fentanyl showing up in their mailbox and
literally taking the lives of their
children who they find blue in bed I
I've talked to families who won't let
the kids go outside because of the crime
wave that's been facilitated by left
radical policies like the ones John
fetterman has been advocating for but
here's the deal right none of this has
to happen this is all very addressable
I'm a surgeon I'm not a politician we
take big problems we focus on them and
we fix them we do it by uniting by
coming together not dividing
and by doing that we can get ahead but
I've got one question to challenge you
with just one question if you take what
I'm saying to Hearth ask yourself this
and others in your family are you
unhappy with where America is headed
I am and if you are as well
that I'm the candidate for change
I'm a living embodiment of the American
dream I believe we're the land of
opportunity to Land of Plenty I believe
we can balance a budget without
recklessly spending I believe we can
have an Unleashed energy policy that
helps us all I believe that we can have
safe city streets and a secure border so
legal immigrants can come across but you
shut the fentanyl out I believe we can
give Parents Choice and where their kids
go to school we can have affordable
health care but most of all I believe in
you and if you can do this together and
we can I would ask for your vote on
election day God bless you we do have
one final question that's pretty good in
Pennsylvania uh the eyes of the state
are on this debate tonight but on Sunday
they will be on Lincoln Financial Field
in Philadelphia as the state's two NFL
teams go head-to-head Mr fetterman
Steelers or Eagles and why Eagles
oh okay clearly always for the Steelers
oh Mr Oz I'll be at the game rooting for
my Eagles Fly Eagles Fly
gentlemen thank you both so much
that's really going to be important at
the voting box this one okay I'm sorry
that was really hard for me you guys
like
I want it so hard uh just to like scream
every time fetterman spoke because he
wasn't saying things and this is the
important point about fetterman and
Biden is it my job to translate for you
what he's saying what what
baleen he said baleen like yo we make
fun of tuna pressure next fluorescent
Etc et cetera yo he's got I think like
15 new words in that at least and it's
no it's the representative's job to
translate your feelings into policy it's
not your job to translate the
representative I like to make up new
words but this is on another level even
far beyond it's the machine it's the
party of the machine and they put people
forward because the people the candidate
doesn't matter it's the machine that's
behind them yeah that's absolutely true
the big money behind it gigander says am
I the only one to find the Dr Oz and
medically disabled fetterman debate
ironic
you know uh I will say this because we
we have a bunch of stuff we can talk
about I want to talk about Kanye for
sure
this was
Dr Oz I think he did he did a decent job
um I was surprised he actually answered
some of these questions fetterman didn't
seem to understand what was going on no
no joke it's not just that he he needs
the machine so you'll notice there were
two monitors one was transcribing and
one was delayed transcribing probably
because if he has to like look back and
forth if he misses something
but how many times has Oz got to say
like I'm not going to cut Social
Security and then Federman goes who's
going to cut Social Security it's almost
like he couldn't understand what was
being said when Oz was like I'm going to
digitize portions of our education
system and get rid of the administrative
staff bloat and then Federal's like you
didn't even answer the question he's
like I did I said I'm gonna and like you
repeated the answer that was just I was
dead I don't know if there's enough
words to describe or an effective word
to describe how painful that was they
clearly coached fetterman he had some
canned lines that he put in there he had
practiced saying Roe v weighed like four
thousand times so he had you know they
gave him some coaching and then thought
they could let him loose but it just
didn't work what's what's up with him
saying words the same way every time bro
v Wade because I I support wrote v Wade
and I I'm for rope wait it was almost
like you ever listen to those automatic
voice things where it's like hello you
have reached and it's because the word
was recorded one time and then the
program splice them together so it like
doesn't that's what it sounded like
that to me was nuts what we were
watching right there is the Republicans
winning the Senate I gotta say I don't
I'm not a huge fan of Dr I mean I don't
hate him I think he got my vote if I had
to vote in that election man
laser focused compared to the other
option we've been making fun of Dr Oz I
think he's he's a bit goofy but here I
just watched two guys and you know you
guys ever watched that Family Guy
episode where they hire an ugly chick to
stand next to Meg this is a fan so
because so by comparison she looks more
attractive that's exactly what that was
I thought Dr Oz was bad I'm sitting here
thinking to myself Kathy Barnett could
be there running circles and then Dr us
he didn't he didn't do bad he had some
good answers his closing statement not
bad not bad
um his talk about college I think
college is dumb but talking about like
you said digitizing elements and getting
the the below from the administrative
staff I'm like I actually like that and
then federman's like you didn't even say
anything and it's like whoa dude when
fed look normally in politics Donald
Trump let's say you got Trump and Biden
or something or know Biden's not a good
example because he's very similar but
let's say you've got like you know guy a
guy guy B
one guy might say like I'm going to
lower gas prices by doing a tax holiday
the other guy says you're not even
proposing a real plan to lower prices
that's an argument right because you can
argue that a tax holiday is not
permanent and then everyone argues when
fetterman says you didn't answer it it
just sounds like he's unable to
comprehend what's being said next to him
but I want to warn everybody we're all
saying like I just said we're watching
the Republicans win the Senate you know
they voted for Biden they voted for
Biden despite Trinity pressure and all
that stuff actually he may have said
that after the campaign or whatever but
the point is we all knew Biden was
hiding in the basement we knew he wasn't
going to campaign and maybe that's why
maybe the Democrats knew that if Biden
went out and actually tried to debate
more than a few times or campaign it
would be endless commercials of
gibberish garbled nonsense and that's
why they don't have him do it he kept
calling a lid and hiding I was wondering
if that was like the technique if they
make people feel bad for him literally
feel so bad for him like oh well we'll
just give it to him I don't know I
wasn't asking to see if you think that
was even like a thing they would try I
have no idea but like I said you know I
just looked it up half a you know a
quarter of a billion dollars rather in
this race 250 million dollars do you
know there's ten thousand
people pulling this you know you know
all sorts of consultants and they've
come out with they think they can win
this they obviously think that they can
win this and after this I don't know but
I'm just they think he's the way to go
I'm imagining some like
campaign PR guy who's like sitting in
the office smoking a cigar and he goes
fetterman and they're like what are you
kidding like you just had a stroke is
like trust me yeah and then it's like
this radical plan where he's like this
city slicker salesman he's like people
are going to want to vote for the guy
who can't talk straight you're mad we're
gonna lose this and then they're gonna
pull out a victory somehow wouldn't be
surprised they did that joke I don't
remember what it was but when Bush was
George W Bush was president I remember
seeing some comedy skits where the joke
was he's folksy and an idiot in public
fetterman and then behind the scenes
he's like Mr Burns or some like
ridiculous intelligence well the the gag
we brought a couple times is that like
Joe Biden's on stage he got lost
recently he's like where are we going
and then as soon as he walks behind the
curtain he stands up straight and goes
all right
let's get back to work ladies and
gentlemen
did they believe it they believed it sir
good
if people actually thought I was of
sound mind I'd be going down with Hunter
Biden at the same time what if there was
like a pollster being like Oh a lot of
people are getting Strokes nowadays
that's relatable that's the best in this
guy and again a quarter billion dollars
that's a lot of money that we're talking
about here and again if you invest that
much you think you're gonna let someone
quit halfway no that's money down the
drain so I think you know this poor guy
is being pushed out there obviously when
you have a mental uh injury when you
when you have a severe brain injury you
need to rest you need to take it easy
you shouldn't be on a debate stage with
what New York Times is calling the most
watched debate of this political season
wow this is this is not okay and it's
not good to watch I felt uncomfortable
watching it and this is truly a
disservice not only to the people of
Pennsylvania but the people of the
United States I want to believe
I want to believe that come tomorrow
come The Day After Tomorrow When the
polls roll in the polling is going to
flip ah this is going to take the lead
and with the with the all already bias
in the polling system we're going to be
looking at Oz winning again I find Oz a
little bit goofy but hey better than
fetamine for a lot of reasons I want to
believe it but come on guys they voted
for Biden isn't there a strong
possibility people watch that and said
don't know don't care well the thing is
people really didn't like Trump that's
what Biden had his Ace in the Hole and
people don't really dislike Oz they
might you know have some issues here and
there with them but let Trump evoked the
ire in humans I think like and no one
come before that I've ever seen I think
the reason Trump may have endorsed Ozzy
because people do like him and his
attitude was like look Oz is a celebrity
he's a people person he's a people
pleaser and we're we're politicos so we
are like Kathy Barnett was the right
option but Trump I mean Trump knows his
stuff he's probably thinking PR wise
you've got a famous TV doctor or Kathy
Barnett who we respect more but she's
very much hyper political take policy
out of it think of what a normal person
who doesn't know anything about politics
thinks after seeing this there's a guy I
respect him he's polished he's clearly
articulate he's got a med degree you
know I've seen him on TV that's him okay
he's fine then there's another guy he
looks like a bub I feel a little bad for
him he shouldn't be up there no of
course he shouldn't be up there do you
think they put fetterman on the on stage
right because of his neck if they if
they put fetterman stage left the camera
angle would have showed shown the
massive growth or whatever he's got on
his neck yeah they control and
micromanage almost every aspect of this
debate uh the questions that are
specifically asked are a lot of times
random sometimes they're leaked to the
candidate just like we saw with Donna
Brazil and Hillary Clinton but when it
comes to the stage the breaks the time
everything is negotiated between the two
candidates so it wouldn't surprise me if
fetterman said and his campaign said hey
we want to be on this side of the stage
and you know they they debate that all
the time and they negotiate someone
someone super chatted sobik mentioned
that if fetterman wins he's going to
step down for health reasons and then
give assuming Shapiro wins the
governorship an appointment
yeah wow that's what it'll be
interesting someone totally
uncharismatic like a very very dark
person wow they couldn't win I'd love
Yeah Yeah somebody
yeah yeah some kind of Ruthless
corporate Banker head is just seething
to just suck the blood out of the poor
working class Blue Collar people of
Pennsylvania just like most politicians
but they're literally going to point
mumia mumia I don't know who that is
never mind it's a big Philly thing he
shot a cop never mind
and there was a big controversy with
Snapple and and that as well yeah that's
a big case mumia Abu Jamal yes political
activist uh yeah that way they did in
New York that what they did in New York
I was just listening and I do not want
to start making fun of John fetterman
having a post-stroke hard time talking
but that what they did in New York even
Oz started to mesh his words because
he's sitting next to fetterman like in
that state of mind it's crazy but that's
what they did in New York with Kathy
hokel they just put her in position of
power yeah and she's horrible could you
imagine if someone here was unable to
speak or understand and we thought we
would keep doing the show I'm sorry guys
like I I've had days where my like I I
was losing my voice so I'm like can't do
the show yeah they got to take show
comes first and the country comes first
the job comes first right but but I mean
like you know what I'm saying is like
your health does I'm not going to try
and do a Showtime like this you know
what I mean is if someone can't do the
show you got to put the show first and
take them out they can't be part of it
because they're going to ruin the the
process and yeah federmen should not be
here I mean look imagine he's standing
next to he's in the Senate and he's
standing next to an uh McConnell or
somebody and they quickly come up and
say John you got to understand what
we're pushing this bill because it
matters the most that we get inflation
done right now so we got it we got to
cut spending here we gotta cut spending
here we're looking at 2.3 increase you
need to get on board with this I'm not
going to ask you twice and John goes
what he's going to be a terror to work
with I would hate you the staffer do you
think that when they're on when they're
when they're debating and negotiating in
in a senate floor they're going to be
having a big machine so that when
someone walks up to him personally and
says I need you to back me on this one a
Democrat even Democrats need to consider
this for themselves a democrat's going
to walk up and say John vote Yes we need
to get this bill done he's gonna go
I I believe
you know and then they're like great and
then it's gonna come and he's gonna go
no and they're gonna be like what is he
it's like well you supported him dude
but no that's why I think he'll step
down John press wrong button yeah
so if he were to win he would
immediately step down that's that's
something I mean that sounds reasonable
because there's no way this guy can
function in this job this is insane it
would drive all of his compatriots
insane all the Democrats would be hate
the guy they would loathe looking at him
when he walked in because what a mockery
is making of American of Law and Order
or political system like uh it's amazing
that the people even had the patience to
put him on TV like that I know it's
going to happen tomorrow because I know
it's already happening right now
across this great nation there are many
a meme Smith sitting at their computers
clipping away and producing mashups
songs Auto Tunes
it's just going to be insane tomorrow
because when you when you have this guy
remember when he said recently he was
like send me to Washington so why for a
PO to push work for work and you're like
what did he just say bro I'm sorry man
I'm not trying to be mean but the dude
didn't say words I mean he said words
but they don't go together
imagine we just got an hour of that an
hour fairly inquiry was going to say he
he did great though they're going to
translate for him yeah this is what they
do for Joe Biden Joe Biden will be like
you know inflation It's gotta because
it's too high and good you know we're
gonna work and it'll make it you know
down and then the news report the paper
will say like Joe Biden said that
inflation was too high and that we need
to get it reduced immediately with
ellipses no they won't even put a quote
they'll be like Joe Biden would Express
outrage over High inflation costs and
promise to get the price down when is
when his quote is bad enough where he
says like come on man and like the
prices you know very high those ellipses
a little bit Biden said quote you know
the prices are too high dot we got to
get them down but if it's too much
gibberish they're I'm willing to bet
this tomorrow a bunch of the papers all
Democrat supporting aren't going to
quote him directly they're going to say
in response to a question from Oz
fetterman expressed X Y and Z he that
exactly I have a counter Viewpoint I I
think he this is again just speculation
here is going to win is going to become
one of the biggest politicians out there
and I think there's going to be a Biden
fetterman 2024 ticket to absolutely take
it because what better opportunity for
multinational corporations than to of
course embed people in candidates that
actually don't know what's going on that
could just rubber stamp all of their
policies which happens right now
according to my own personal opinion
with the Biden Administration I think
it's clear as day he's not in charge
here the people who put him in charge
they're the one calling the shots here
they're the ones pushing the great reset
they're the ones building back better
they're the ones destroying the American
economy and of course stopping domestic
energy exploration and production which
is deliberately creating an energy
crisis right the uh the campaign slogan
for Biden fetterman 2024 is going to be
like bertafon forgive come on you know
Shabba and people are going to be like
what it's funny but it's true I mean
like a lot of people study how white
houses are structured and with Trump I
mean if he had something had happened to
him you know everything would have been
chaos because everything went up to the
top it was very personal with Biden you
know you've got all these little czars
you've got Ron Klein Gina McCarthy
podesta in there as well podesta if
Biden goes away the machine continues to
Clack because it he doesn't matter and I
think it's the same with Iron Man he
doesn't matter I wanna I'm sorry I just
need to stress this before we wrap up
this you know segment I want you all to
realize where we are as a nation
we're at a point where one of the oldest
and most prominent political parties had
decided to run someone with a severe
mental disability restricting their
ability to comprehend words that are
said before them
we can make a little bit more crass
we are at the point where the Democrats
are running
and have run and won with brain damaged
candidates I'm not saying that to dig at
fetterman I'm not using brain damage as
a kind of insult it is a fact Joe Biden
I believe had an aneurysm and he got
metal plates put in his brain he
struggles to speak fetterman recently
within the past what was it five months
ago had a stroke I feel bad I do not
wish that on anybody
you gotta know when to bow out but here
we are in America
this is the point where this nation is a
man with a severe mental disability just
in a debate stage for an hour and and
there are there are prominent media and
activists who are acting like this is
good and okay and the right person to
vote for they may as well may have well
in my opinion conceded the race
immediately to Oz and I do not
understand what they're hoping to gain
out of this
oh geez I hope people can see reality I
really do I I don't know how distortive
I know drugs can really mess people up
perception wise and you don't see things
that are happening sometimes food also
I'm afraid can do that but I hope to God
people see that that debate and see it
for what it was
there was a really funny moment where he
just said I just believe when she was
like how are you going to get cost out I
just believe it and it's like that sums
up the Democrat position a lot of things
yeah and also randomly yelling and
screaming yeah doesn't really make you
look strong no
okay
let's talk about the uh the Civil War
that's coming how about that guys we
gotta go and drink take a shot everybody
drink all right Arizona Sheriff steps up
security around ballot drop boxes amid
reports of intimidation I wanted to ask
you guys about this because we have this
story uh some guys were wearing
bulletproof vests they had guns they're
in their uh Maricopa County and they're
uh sitting next to some ballot drop
boxes
apparently there's an organization
that's advocating for watching these
ballot boxes and I said this was going
to happen I said be you know after like
2 000 mules and after a lot of these
claims people are going to go to the
drop boxes and they are going to watch
then you're eventually going to see
antifa show up we've already had one
woman jump confront on the cops got
called
now the sheriff is sending I guess
Security Police to monitor these boxes
and uh I don't know does this escalate
the what the bulwark wrote and you know
we're all big fans of the bulwark
they're the conservative neocons who
hate Republicans it's weird they wrote
that their their their scenario that
they fear for escalation of civil war is
that at a polling location on the
midterms someone is there observing
someone on the right they're armed they
see someone who they think is committing
fraud or something a fight breaks out a
gunshot rings out a poll workers on the
ground bleeding someone films it that
was their scenario my scenario is
simpler
two guys show up they got bulletproof
vests and they got guns they're watching
the ballot Dropbox
a leftist walks up to him starts
screaming saying get out of here you're
white supremacists a scuffle breaks out
nothing serious
the police are called and the police are
forced to start pushing people back
nobody can vote the polling location is
now closed and dispute arises as to
whether or not the election can be
legitimate if polling locations are
being shut down
I don't know where we go from here
people don't have faith in these in
these drop boxes and just to take it
back a little bit I think it was Philly
where they had the new the Black Panther
Party that was intimidating voters back
maybe a decade ago or whatever nothing
happened so it goes back
you know we've had scuffles at polling
locations I think it was John Calhoun's
father who took guns to the legislature
to to get his own District or whatever
so fights occur in these places but
people do need to have faith we need
cameras we need enforcement mechanisms
to make sure that there aren't you know
thousands of ballots being dropped off
it happened in Muskegon County in
Michigan I'm hearing stuff in Wisconsin
already you know I think it's happening
right now yeah I think it's happening I
think the question too is
which states allow ballot harvesting and
what you don't because some do well I
mean even in Wisconsin you know where I
served on Election Day and then helped
out with that investigation later
um you know there was a Supreme Court
decision there where they said you know
you can't ballot Harvest but I'm still
hearing that people come in with bags do
you object and they don't listen to you
so it doesn't matter if the law on the
books is one thing if there's no way for
you to enforce it well I think I think
the issue right now depending on where
this goes is simple I think people
should be watching ballot boxes I think
there should be cameras I think there
should be security uh hold on let me
slow down there shouldn't be ballot drop
boxes at all we should not have election
month we should have election day it
should be a Federal holiday people
should get time off to be able to go and
vote and then enjoy a nice beer and
pizza with their friends afterwards or
whatever but if we're gonna have any
kind of polling location then I think we
should have security cameras on
everything
that's it the crazy thing to me is how
is it vote the doj is getting involved
now calling it voter intimidation how is
it intimidating someone that you're
sitting there watching like you're
allowed to be in public you're allowed
to be armed you're allowed to wear armor
none of that is a crime if they start
screaming at people and chasing after
them and stuff yeah okay there you go
but they're claiming that someone came
up and then some people started taking
pictures of them and they're like that's
intimidation and it's like bro you're in
public it's the it's a different law but
it's the same story that we had with the
face act which is the freedom to access
Clinic entrances which they used against
abortion protesters that often would
just they're using right now right
they're using right now but but there
were some Supreme Court cases and you
can't be as aggressive but yeah they're
still using it here's another law where
they creatively apply it to people to to
get their preferred preferred ends so I
don't know what do you guys think is
going to happen
geez you want to go for it no you go
ahead oh man regarding these I kind of
agree I just think in general not even
just this I think where do we what
happens on the eighth unless you create
faith in the voting system as a whole I
think it's gonna slowly unravel and for
that it's like I don't like digitized
voting counting proprietary software
because I don't care if I'm mailing it
in handing it to a guy putting it in a
box and he's carrying it if it's being
tallied by a machine and the code's in
private I don't know if they're flipping
at 51.49 behind the scenes I've actually
seen testimony of like developer that
did that uh Clint Eugene Curtis Clint
Eugene Curtis I don't know if you ever
heard his story but what the he wrote
the software to flip the votes 5149 for
a politician so Democrats were were
making the same claims or Trump
supporters are making and you see the
Hillary Clinton thing already Hillary
Clinton came out and said the
Republicans are planning on stealing
2024. it's okay it's okay when she does
it it's it's you know I don't even I
don't even care at this point I'm just
like
the Democrat and Republican culture the
liberal and conservative culture is by
for it's it's two two distinct things
two completely different realities and
it's been that way for a long time and
now you've got both sides accusing each
other of cheating
I don't care who you think is right left
right up down whatever the fact is two
factions think both sides are stealing
the election both sides disagree with
each other's culture what how does that
resolve itself yeah is it is you know
just seriously to the people who think
it's silly when I say things like Civil
War do you think the end result is going
to be that like Hillary Clinton walks up
to Trump and says how could I stay mad
at you and then Trump's like come here
and they hug is it gonna be like the BLM
marcher with the black mascot and the
molotov see the Trump supporter with the
Maga flag and then he drops the mile
time and goes what have I become and the
Trump supporters come to your buddy and
they hug is there a Pepsi there and yeah
Kylie Jenner that could work hey do they
think that Kylie Jenner is going to walk
up to a BLM and Trump supporter and hand
them both Pepsis then they're gonna both
look at each other and then hug
seriously though for what reason at any
point would any of this de-escalate I'm
looking for a legitimate
argument yeah I don't see it I don't see
any form of de-escalation I'm seeing a
lot of people adding fuel to the fire
I'm seeing this getting totally out of
hand this this building up of of calling
elections illegitimate has been
happening for many years now the
groundwork has been set for this uh
specifically when we look at you know
the Trump election the the Russian
collusion and all the people coming
forward saying I don't trust this
election I don't trust this voting box I
don't trust this voting machine and I
think there are some you know legitimate
questions I think a lot of people are
also sensationalistic and hyperbolic in
a way that doesn't serve anyone's
interest but at the end of the day you
know that's a good question that you
asked here and that's something that
I've been thinking about for a very long
time and I see no off-road I see no way
of stopping this train coming ahead of a
major disaster inside of the United
States the only thing that I can see
that can fix this is if you do have one
party and I would say probably
Republican you know Landslide so that
their side can see faith in it and then
they win again and there's some kind of
strong agenda that they put in place
that can bring people to heels but if
the Republicans wins the Democrats down
is about the only way that I can see
that this works excuse me wrong no no
uh I don't I don't agree
um I think that if we see an
overwhelming Republican Victory like
Luke was saying the Democrats will claim
the Republicans cheated the countries
become fascist and already there is this
viral tweet where someone said well
democracy is over what are you know what
are you going to do and someone
responded with I'm going to join the
resistance now look I'm not I'm not
confident the left has the ability to
form any meaningful resistance but
you need to you know uh I've been
harping on this because I've been
reading a lot more about the Civil War
The South was was a lot of States uh
relatively but not a lot of people it
was like two to one north to south they
were the minority a substantial minority
and then slave owners were an even
smaller minority
so
you know we may think like Democrats
might break Republican and independent
but looking at Hillary Clinton and her
cohorts and the cult members there's a
strong faction there and they're not
going to accept a trump Victory now now
here's a scenario to imagine
there's a Supreme Court ruling that's
coming soon that could set that may set
the precedent the state legislatures
decide who gets the electoral votes I
mean that's literally what the
Constitution says and for the longest
time the legislators have said oh we'll
do it we'll do an election
the people of our state vote
and then they vote for the electors to
go and do it we don't appoint them but
according to the Constitution the State
Legislative legislature could appoint
the Electoral the electors however they
see fit it is to be determined to buy
them the way the country's supposed to
work we vote for our state reps Senators
Representatives they then represent us
to the federal government we've slowly
changed that with the popular vote for
the president and with the 17th
Amendment the popular vote for the
Senate that could change if this ruling
goes down imagine this scenario
2024 election
Donald Trump versus
Joe Biden whatever
the popular votes come in Biden gets it
the Statewide votes come in Electoral
College goes to Joe Biden but hold on
there a minute
lawsuits are immediately filed
questions are arise poll observers
Witnesses testimony comes out several
States say we cannot issue a
determination at this time this puts the
Electoral College up in the air two
things could happen
we could see the house do a simple vote
we saw this base off of house
delegations there was a concern that in
2020 because I think there were 26 house
delegations that were Republican or
something like that Donald Trump would
have won if it was pushed to a house
delegation vote
with this Supreme Court ruling something
else could happen
a state like Michigan simply says
evidence has been brought to our
attention which leads us to believe you
know the this amount of votes or that
amount of votes are not not uh correct
or are illegitimate therefore we as the
state legislature nullify them
the victory goes to Donald Trump
what would the left do in that position
they'll say Hillary Clinton predicted
this
the extremist Maga Republicans are
stealing the country and then what do
you think they just say but I guess I'll
go hang out at home this has happened
before I mean there have been there have
been cases where states have flipped and
I don't I don't see anything wrong with
that process per se I mean you know the
whole thing about
you know you can you can get into
Republican form of government problems
if the state legislature's not even
holding an election or something like
that but at the end of the day there
have to be processes in place to to
count the votes to make sure that
there's a state actor who's certifying
things and sending them to the archivist
and and whatnot so I I don't see a
problem it's happened before I guess the
main thing I'll say is I don't really
see that as happening because
you know look at what happened in 2020
Mike Pence you know wouldn't look under
the hood nobody looked under the hood
you know you go state after State people
don't check under the hood because
they've got people beating down their
door so I don't see that happening you
gave Michigan as an example I don't see
you know Sharky or whatever his name is
the the lead at the legislature there uh
entertaining that sort of a thing
um you know time and time again Arizona
Michigan Wisconsin
um you see weak weak Republican
leadership that doesn't do that so I
don't I don't really see that as as a as
so much of a possibility I see the more
thing I see is is States battening down
the hatches in these purple areas on
behalf of blue candidates it's all very
dubious and no one ever has their their
views aired out nobody ever checked
under the hood so the clips are coming
yeah right already I got one from
regular rice anything we can play the
beginning we actually missed the
beginning when fetterman said hi good
night really yeah I I reposted that one
yeah so fetterman is asked to clarify
whether he supports fracking quote I
support fracking and I don't I support
fracking and I stand and I do support
fracking
great
I love how they brought out the
information and he immediately says I
never supported fracking it's like we
literally just read on the screen that
said You supported fracking in 2018 I
don't know how you're gonna how you're
gonna debate that or like the other way
around that he didn't support fracking
in 20 no matter he didn't I think he
said he did the thing about fracking and
nobody really brought it up is when they
first were doing it it was really uh
dirty and they've Advanced the chemicals
that they inject in underground so it's
a lot cleaner right from what I've heard
there's an EPA thing it wasn't like the
workers it was like the the runoff and
stuff like that I just want to see
someone splice his answer about I get
knocked down and I get up again I want
to see things yeah yeah
to the victim mindset like if you're a
victim then I'm your guy yeah victims
versus surgeon I'm a surgeon yeah versus
a guy who saves people's lives did you
know I was a surgeon
surgery by bringing people together
David harassany says if Dasha Burns was
guilty of anything it was downplaying
the extensive fetterman's problems and I
recall all the feigned outrage Giselle
fetterman demanding consequences Dasha
Burns interviewed fetterman he had to
use a special device and she said
that during the small talk it wasn't
clear he understood what what she was
saying and a bunch of people on the left
said that it's ableist that someone with
mental disabilities and brain damage
should be allowed to hold office and you
know they were outraged and uh they said
that she was
wrong and it was offensive and that
criticizing fetterman was akin to
criticizing someone who needed reading
glasses
wow Governor Abbott a cursory viewing of
the debate determined that was a lie
Dasha Burns probably could have been a
bit harsher on fetterman
that was CR I can't believe he agreed to
do it I mean Katie Hobbs won't debate
Carrie Lake
fetterman could have just been like nah
he's up two points what is he got to
lose well I think they know the buys and
the polls favors Oz and so he had no
choice
that was bad I mean are they trying to
lose
that crossed my mind but it was kind of
a joke like is is fetterman a plant
trying to get Oz elected like does he
work for Dr Oz are we going to find out
yours friends no he's just a guy that
broke and now but he doesn't want to let
go of what he used to have maybe the
reason he said uh
you know I support fracking and I don't
and so that the Democrats are able to
make a video of him answering however
they want him to answer do you support
for asking I don't fracking I don't I'm
sorry I pulled the Thunderman do you
support fracking I don't I stand and
then they're going to be like oh then
they're one commercial saying it
I think I think Oz should have just been
like the floor is yours John speak just
go for it yeah
I do think Oz needed the chance to
explain his positions though
yeah it was enlightening to listen to
yeah we didn't get into anything else
though we had you know Kanye stuff
what's the Kanye more chats yeah Kanye's
net worth went from what two billion to
one to 600 million ish he's lost about
three fourths as well because it's
Adidas steel was canceled Adidas
canceled they're uh I don't even know
what the deal was but apparently he's
made him worth 1.5 billion dude Yeezys
go for hundreds of dollars easy shoes
they're called I I you know I just like
I've never never wore I've seen I've
seen him before and then I was just like
I ordered I wrote a couple pairs when
they said they were canceling them or
whatever I'm like all right you know
whatever not that I don't think I'm not
going to sell them or anything I'm gonna
put on my shelf and just be like you
know hey these were a thing once it
could have been his uh the Kanye West
Lex Friedman interview was eye-open I
think everybody saw at least a clip from
it did you also a little small clip yeah
yeah it was kind of worth it it was more
of an I think it was an attempt by Lex
to emotionally connect with Kanye and
they were both trying to be like hey we
don't know each other we both are
Engineers of A Sort let's be friends was
the kind to the I what they went into it
and it was contentious and kind of a
mess because I didn't watch it I I read
it and it just read to me as smarmy like
he was talking down to Kanye and trying
to play the what's the problem man I
agree yeah I was I was like There's an
opportunity to have a conversation with
Kanye that's that's that's real and asks
him to you know explain himself better
but I didn't I didn't get that interview
it felt like it was very much like
here's what the media said so I'm gonna
I'm gonna argue with you about it and
Kanye was getting frustrated he was like
dude
and then Lex gave him the do you trust
me and Kanye was like no and Lex was
like why should I devastated yeah why
shouldn't it he doesn't know him I'm
literally I'm so [ __ ] like really hurt
Lex and it's like I mean at some point
Lex you gotta like be a machine you know
it's okay trust is built over
Generations it doesn't happen yeah I
don't trust someone I just met I
wouldn't I wouldn't all right we're
gonna go we're gonna go to super chats
because this is a special debate episode
so smash that like button if you haven't
already subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends we got a we
got a very important members on the
uncensored show coming up having to do
with New York and the Court ruling on
the vaccines and vaccine mandates this
is huge by the way reversing all of
these firings ordering back pay
devastating to those who marched in
locks that but we'll we'll talk about
that for the members only so smash that
like button Let's uh let's talk about
some super chats Elite says Tim I'm from
Michigan and I just watched the Whitmer
Dixon debates Tudor absolutely smashed
her do you think you could reach out and
get her on Michigan needs a new governor
thanks for all you do I mean that'd be
cool I'm down to have some more Governor
Kenneth we've had Kerry Lake we've had
Doug mastriano they were both pretty
they were both uh awesome I think Cara
Lake could be president
she really really knows how to handle
handle herself with the media yeah I
would love to talk to Miss Whitmore
especially about her health care record
when it came to of course putting people
in nursing homes I think that's a big
question that should be asked to her
right now and people should remember the
past of of how she you know helped
murder people
all right AI says seriously Tim AMC's
Rubicon you wanna you wanna write that
down you have a pen yeah what was the
Rubicon it was that joke what's it about
I'll send it to you
uh I wasn't I don't remember what it's
about exactly
um I'll watch it tonight
all right
Raymond g sound like you just says Tim I
must say both shows last night were
fantastic what I appreciate is that
while we can all disagree on many topics
we all still are on the same team unlike
that of the left for the line here here
man here here it's important to debate
and uh challenge your ideas always
all right let's grab some uh
salty ducklings says someone should take
the Hillary Clinton conspiracy video and
put it over the Infowars background oh
that's a really good idea actually
yeah
yeah definitely
all right Rhiannon tunnel says I told my
brother's girlfriend the Constitution
technically gives me the right to keep
and bear nukes she was horrified but had
to agree I was right yeah I'm not wrong
you know these people I think it was
like The Young Turks they were like was
it somebody Tim pool thinks people
should have nuclear weapons I didn't say
they should I said the right to keep and
bear arms they didn't specify you know
like can you have a can you have a
microwave gun
I would imagine yeah I don't know it's
it's like this is the crazy thing we
talked about this with weapons if you if
you're a uh
when your waiter comes to you and hands
you a steak Knife did he just give you a
weapon yeah he did yeah every he handed
you a weapon right
so a reasonable person would probably be
like no it's a steak knife for your
dinner aha but what if he then whispered
in your ear that's your Target and then
pointed to an old person oh now we're
talking imminent threat that's illegal
but see the point is he had to do the
exact same thing context doesn't change
the fact that it is a weapon so when it
comes to keeping bearing arms knives
microwaves whatever Dynamite they're all
weapons
what's not a weapon
I suppose you could argue technically
something that was not designed with the
intent to cause damage to a biological
or or structural entity yeah right I
mean like assault with a deadly weapon
could be a rock a heavy Rock wasn't
designed exactly cheeseburgers whether
or not after the fact what if you shove
a cheeseburger into someone's mouth like
down their throat to block their airways
like would that be assault with a deadly
weapon I don't know maybe in some states
but you weaponized a cheeseburger I
think honestly the fair way to classify
weapons is after the fact because if you
have a a rifle that's never been fired
and it's behind a glass case it's
technically just a a gun it's not a
weapon until you use it well they they
do this in law they do categorize things
ahead of time whether it's a weapon or
not and usually the state law like
includes lists of things and and some
description like a blade that's a
certain length things like that things
for for yeah for switchblade but it's
not accurate because a small knife is a
weapon that a butter knife is a weapon a
rock is a weapon in the right hands or
in the wrong yeah so we're talking about
10 or so different laws one could be
assault with that deadly weapon one
could be possession you can make a
toothbrush yeah for sure toothpick a
toothbrush too they do it all the time
in jail that's right water water is a
weapon I don't think the second
amendment protects toothbrushes though
I'd like to deny that yeah I mean I
don't know man you know look at the way
that I was considered arms
they're not they're well I'm not sure
that knives are considered well maybe
the knives are considered arms yeah sure
sure all right let's uh let's read some
more this isn't a good one from Jen
Desai says if fetamine cannot
communicate without a device in an
emergency where power or Internet fails
he becomes a major liability
I want you to imagine
you decide fetterman should be your rep
and he goes to DC and uh let me ask you
Democrats do you think another something
do you think January 6 could happen
again all right I want you to imagine
fetterman standing there when a January
6 type moment happens what do you think
that man does
nothing look around confused
wondering who's saying what is
everyone's murmuring and screaming and
he's seeing people run every direction
and someone walks up to him and looks
him in the eyes and goes
and he goes I have no idea what's being
said to me right now
and they're saying run you need to run
now and he just stands there confused
like what's happening yeah
I agree I feel like he's uh kind of wait
and be told what to do kind of guy in
the state that he's in right now
unfortunately Connor ski says I had a
stroke three years ago at age 25. I
wouldn't consider myself fit for a job
that's important maybe a good guy but
still look man I I really am saddened by
this I don't wish this on anybody it can
happen to anybody yeah literally same
thing same thing with you know these
people mocking those who get like Bell's
Palsy or whatever I'm like dude there's
a lot of things that cause Bell's Palsy
I've seen stories of people who use like
like wasp spray and then two weeks later
they're like oh the chemical may have
caused something rather than that like I
don't know yeah I just try to say like
you know let's not
let's not drag people for stuff like
that I think he should be criticized
because he should not be in this
position totally he should have walked
away and you should be able to say that
that's the thing you should be able to
say when someone has something that's
in between them and a job you should be
able to say something about it right and
I think they try to put up these walls
like you can't you can't even talk about
it it's ableist Amber Byrd says don't
forget Bill Gates declared there would
be a hung election and then a subsequent
Civil War he is awfully good at
destructive predictions you think that's
that's crazy good predictions uh yeah
yeah he's very good he he's remarkable
so he he said there will be a hung
election well this is I think relating
to the Civil War comment that we were
talking about a couple of days ago Bill
Gates said an interview there will be a
hung election and then a civil war he
didn't say there could be or I hope
there won't be he said there will be
yeah that was freaky yeah yeah he also
has a team that monitors people talking
about him on the internet for some
reason that's kind of kind of weird she
had that much money you do that I mean
to be fair though like we have marketing
people who and and we do track certain
terms for the show and everything so I
don't like listen to
other shows talking about me though you
know but he was specifically talking
about going after quote conspiracy
theorists and uh individuals that are
critical of him his quote was political
polarization may bring it all to an end
we comma we're going to have a hung
election and a civil war that's complete
insane I mean first of all definitive
yeah he's just he's just making an
assumption is he yeah a nice one for all
you know assumption look at that guy
agreeing with us yeah we were we made
faces early because you were like on a
step on it or something no I took some I
thought you were gonna crush it and I
was like don't do it don't because
because it was on George Washington no
because it like it releases us I've
gotten rid of him before without it
without you got to freeze them yeah
freeze them yeah yeah I use like the
duster and then they just instantly
freeze and then they don't release this
thing yeah the CIA bugs are everywhere
we're gonna come back to life right away
we're in a place where people it's like
one person's prediction versus another
person's prediction and who believes who
and if you if enough people believe the
one prediction then they're gonna start
living that life to make that prediction
reality and you know whatever they're
gonna look back and be like he was a
prophet he was a prophet that kind of
thing yeah he controls people by saying
it Lord John einerson says got my spot
in Scotland Next to You Tim awesome
sponsor uh I added the word Lord because
now apparently he's he's gone to
um
to our sponsor's website and uh who is
it uh Lord John einerson einerson he got
his uh his established titles your
newest neighbor established titles.com
timpool I'm now a neighbor and we're
landowners in Scotland we were making a
joke about about this earlier like do we
get air rights like do we get mineral
rights can I drill down into my one
square foot find oil and then like build
like a one square foot massive oil pump
the whole machine fits into one square
foot hey the oil is mine
we'll see
and and does that mean like you can't
hold office in the U.S anymore I hope
not I've also got a title I don't think
I'm up in the highlands you're up in the
highlands yeah let us not come to blows
so I looked it up us doesn't Grant
titles and an office holder can't accept
a title but if you're not an office
holder and you accept it ahead of time
maybe it's maybe it's good you know all
right Justin says Tim please read
Vandenberg space Force Base com Squadron
releasing member health information
others forcing out member for
identifying unauthorized Network on base
and going to ig member supervisor worked
in base IG leadership culture of New
Branch not great interesting
all right Omega rasetsu says Tim I would
like to correct you on something you
stated on your four o'clock segment the
National Guard is federal with the added
step of the governor being in the chain
of command the uniform still says U.S
army right but what what I mean to say
is
yesterday I said you're going to get
like California they have a national
California National Guard
the National Guard is not an individual
is not going to want to be occupying
their own neighborhood or town they
don't want to be that person I mean who
would for the most part some people
might you know and then someone said Tim
the California National Guard won't be
enforcing Federal mandate in California
and I said right they're not going to
send people to their own neighborhoods
but if they do uh invoke the
Insurrection act and deploy military you
may end up with people from whatever
Branch who are from a specific area
being like I will not bear arms against
my home neighborhood sorry I won't do it
so my point was ultimately that you're
going to see State divisions you're
going to see people in the military
choose to decide with their state not
because they care about their state but
because they care about where their
family lives and they don't want to be
the one pointing a gun at their friends
that's it
we'll see though man I don't know who
knows how things play out history
doesn't repeat it rhymes
chanston ippolito
says 23 chance for a second stroke zero
percent chance to finish a sentence
without sounding like a robot this
debate is uncomfortable to watch no
different than the feeling following a
Biden speech the Republic deserves
better
the people of Pennsylvania they can vote
for their own destruction I mean that's
crazy man
that's just sad
Charles not given says my first Super
Chat is heartbreakingly sad a man that
is struggling to make his brain work
like it used to and another mocking him
for it saying his policies are things in
his imagination
is that mocking Oz no I think they're
talking about John fetterman that it's
it's he's become a mockery
but I I agree with that and I think that
if he rested for a few years that he
could actually run reasonably for office
like if you let your brain recover but
right now it's just so soon that's
what's crazy for me because I had a
brain injury in 2015 and it's insane to
me that he would do that like what how
was in May yeah it's utterly insane to
me that he would go on the end of the
day into a debate on a national level
and try and answer questions like that
if he can't even read the the prom it's
just I can't even imagine that's why
he's sweating so much you know how he's
like having to read all those things and
pay attention all this stuff I cannot I
do not understand what was the recovery
like for you
um like I said before and on the I think
we did a member segment but it took me
like I thought after a year I was okay
but then after like three or four years
I was like Wow after a year I was still
not recovered whatsoever took me a lot
longer and I just don't I can't even
imagine hit a stroke dude it's a whole
other level was it like confusion is the
main problem is there
um confusion also just like being able
to speak and and do simple things or
like I had a frontal lobe injury so
mainly like my um you know like my
forward planning or future planning and
uh my emotional control was was wild it
was wildly difficult just to be able to
have conversations and you know just
keep it together in a sense at least
initially so he's within a year that
dude is I don't even know he's
definitely being pushed by people to do
this I would think
I mean they probably would you say a
quarter of a billion dollars yeah so
they probably went to him and he was
probably I wouldn't be surprised if he
was like I'm sorry I can't do this in
fact I would be surprised if he went I
you know I'm I'm sorry I I can't and
they said we have put a quarter of a
billion dollars but is that between Oz
and him or just him Oz and him but see I
don't know about that because
you don't run for office if you're not a
narcissist of I mean like a politician
dislike a politician they all think they
can do it they all think they're great
so I mean I hope that he has that I mean
that's dark if they did that but really
it's more likely in my mind that he's
like yeah I can do this I can do this a
lot of politicians are so sociopaths
yeah so why do we love them mostly
Democrats and then largely Republicans
but there's a handful of good
Republicans oh sure because for whatever
reason they have some like libertarian
more libertarian-minded people more
America first-time people
yeah it's important to love yourself and
have faith in yourself but not cross the
border of narcissism I've met some
genuinely decent politicians I think Joe
Kent has won Jeff sessions definitely a
gentleman but for the most part and I
would think fetterman too I mean for the
most part uh certainly yeah Ian says the
Dems are pure evil for make for making
this man stand on the stage in front of
the world it hurts my heart in all
honesty to watch this tragedy I kind of
agree honestly
but you know it has to happen in this
environment Joe Biden is the president
if he's really suffering cognitive
decline we have to confront this head-on
yeah I mean we we we briefly turned the
debate off I was like we can't do this
this is insane he's not saying anything
it's just garbled nonsense
people people need to hear it I guess so
they should have asked him his opinion
on Joe Biden's cognitive decline yeah be
cool if the candidates could ask each
other questions like huh nah I think
that would get crazy too dirty yeah
because they you'd ask a question that
you knew was not true for the sake of
being accusatory like Ian when did you
stop beating your wife you know what I
mean hey you leave me out of this right
I say put boxing gloves on them and then
be like ask whatever you want try a
election by combat I like that idea yeah
I choose not to debate I choose to win
the election by combat and then you put
them both in the ring and Tetris
Thunderdome yeah what if what if it was
a debate underdome a physical physical
contest like an obstacle course like
Ninja Warrior a physical battle like
American Gladiators and a mental battle
like chess and they have to do all of
these things I would love it American
Ninja Warrior just DePaul a bunch of
eight it would get rid of the 80 year
olds one guy would drink the mushroom
tea beforehand I got all these bonuses
and then you might have to screen them
and if you're physically fit you're
mentally fit as well usually this is
idiocracy accelerationism yeah might as
well happening no no this idea is is
good yeah yeah like the idea that in
order to be a politician you have to be
more than just uh good at speaking yeah
what do we get we get a bunch of smooth
talkers silver tongues and snake oil
make it so that you have to be
physically fit you have to be mentally
fit and you have to actually win win the
votes and not be a coward right so to
fight somebody yeah I know what it means
to get punched in the face I think a lot
of people don't know what it means to
get punched so that's a way to fix it
have them fight each other let's go
let's make it happen
yeah like you earn you earn a vote like
a like a .01 times Advantage Plus on all
the votes you receive if you win the
chess match when you win the boxing
match when you win the obstacle course
hey Bob you've got his ass beat but at
least he now knows what it means to get
your ass beat and he's not going to be
talking trash that he's not going to try
to start another War hopefully uh you
know Legacy production says Oz's lucky
fetterman has has health health issues
even with his speech fetterman is taking
points away from Oz and saying agreeable
things I won't completely disagree with
that I think it was really bad but you
know fetterman
he he there was there was one point I
can't remember exactly what he said but
I was like okay that wasn't so bad that
wasn't so bad I like this thing on China
I thought that was coherent from front
to back and then Oz had something about
you know yes what's the most important
American foreign policy problem yeah and
Oz was like something something you know
invade in Iran Iran China was the right
answering strength that we we seem weak
to the rest of the world I think it's
Central Banking neither of them
mentioned it was disappointed the Mad
machinist says given Biden's success
this guy is a shoe-in for the position
that's the sad thing isn't it
yeah ghost pepper what what does this
mean he said Baby Ruth
what Baby Ruth that's baby that sloth
yells that he wants a Baby Ruth and he
will give it to him that's right
oh is that is that it baby
why am I laughing I feel bad John Meyer
says is Hector Salamanca a moderator
that I liked that one because I recently
watched weird
dude yeah
yeah well but what that was going
I feel like that show should have ended
at season four
like they dragged it on with the next
one yeah well they're making money at
that point right that it was like at its
height about season four is when the
world was obsessed with it the most hmm
all right barely insane says fetamine
almost sounds like Norm Macdonald doing
a bit but instead of being funny it's
sad yeah true oh it's a really important
one wow leor Leo engelstein uh brilliant
he writes have you ever had a dream that
that um that you had uh that you had to
you could you you do you wit you uh you
could do so you could do you want you
wanted him to do you so much you could
do anything
well I got that part of it I wanted him
to do you and the answer I I just I want
not to start to make fun of people with
mental disabilities because of this
stuff but putting him up there it makes
him a mockery this has been said before
on this show I don't need to reiterate
but I really want to have compassion for
people that are suffering from mental
injuries of any kind yeah absolutely man
but get him out of public office right
yeah I mean he's currently Lieutenant
lieutenant governor that's time to
resign John yep
all right gem R says In fairness to
fetterman I just believe is the most
honest answer I've ever heard a Democrat
give about how they plan to make their
Utopia happen
agreed
all right
ingrate says but you know those feelings
over facts are going to love fetterman's
position on education what was his
position I I don't know I don't know he
had one did he yeah I thought he didn't
say anything other than that you didn't
answer the you know uh it's the baleen
he said baleen that was one of the words
he said baleen
yeah yeah his his am I gonna try am I
supposed to I'm not gonna translate that
for him well those are the things the
whale yeah they sifted the Krill through
that yeah it's called baleen baleen he
was talking about whales yeah it is I I
am not I I do not play these games if
you say the wrong word you said it you
said it
and they expect the journalists to come
out here and start fixing it for them
you can hear some meme forges firing up
right now
okay let's grab uh what do we got here
Wise Guys in Texas how are you not doing
a drinking game watching this if Dems
were saying or informed Republicans just
swept Pennsylvania yo if we did a
drinking game that like every time
fetterman said something that made no
sense we would all be completely
obliterated we'd have slammed all of the
remaining whiskey that we have and we've
been begging for you please stop in an
hour wow
it's not good for you it shrinks your
brain
let's see what we got here a lot of
people are basically saying the same
thing so
you know
Ryan ferris's first Super Chat for my
33rd birthday loved the show happy
birthday Ryan
we have this one from Christopher
Fairley sobik is saying if fetterman
wins he steps down for health reasons
and wolf or Shapiro appoints his wife
oh interesting yeah
no you're there with his wife
fetterman's wife yeah she likes some hot
shot I don't know don't know
Probot says fetterman will appoint his
wife Peck Biden already said she would
do well it's already planned we will see
a lot of people thought Kamala Harris
was going to take over that Biden was
going to step down due to health reasons
it could still happen I suppose she's
not fetterman what's her excuse
I don't know this is his wife Giselle
Barreto fetterman Brazilian American
activist Dragon stallions is all I heard
fetterman say was I support it because I
don't support it that's right I was like
what
I support it but I don't support it
huh
well okay dude
Cricket smile says damn Ian be brighten
up the place with that orange beanie hey
yo
glad you like it everyone's wearing a
beanie except the me and you it's true
it was odd on like the the actual I need
the breakdown it was two you guys on the
other side on the left side
here's a good one yeah but Trump says
lies Luke's made up vocabulary far
exceeds Biden and fetterman's put
together
all right as a troop that is Fair Point
hmm
maybe lucasms why don't you should make
a shirt with all the we should like
write down the real definitions of what
they yeah no right yeah yeah like uh
like Simpsons made cromulent and then
big and happen you know that yeah I've
heard you say words like it'll be like
uh two things sounds that aren't a word
but you put them together and it makes
sense yeah it might make sense at least
right thank you Ian I appreciate it what
are you guys hiding underneath the
beanies there's something underneath
there isn't it warm head my friend a
warm hat what about you Tim what do you
got under the beanie nothing literally
it's uh it's a portal it's um it it it's
a atomist will come out if I take the
beanie off so I can't uh yeah anybody
who understands that reference you and
brownie points I'm sure most people
probably well actually I don't know did
you I think surge got it right
um nope that's enough no no none of you
got it what are you sailing from finals
will come out of my head if I take the
beanie off
where's where's who's who's gonna who's
gonna get the reference watching the
chat but honestly I'm cheating I'm
looking it up online
atomos
Atomic oh atomisk yeah it makes it easy
all right you look it up and we'll read
some more
all right where we got what do we got
here
Conga fool says
Luke if DeSantis runs for president will
you try to make shirts for him AKA make
America Florida shirts we already have
make America Florida shirts I think
that's a great statement yeah so you
find it yeah the chat already figured it
out
also known as the pirate king that's
right kaizoku the pirate king okay zoku
oh is that how you say it yes they they
the space travel in fully cooly is is uh
achieved through between the hemispheres
the brain I saw flcl in the chat I've
seen that show yeah I've seen the whole
thing I just don't remember the word no
me either yeah that was a great show
microwave yeah only six episodes and
then they tried remaking and that's
phenomenal no one I don't think anyone
cared for the remakes no that was just
gorgeous it's so emotional and it's like
such a 90s throwback too like the music
everything is great oh it's yeah it's
such a good show
yeah shout out fully Cooley that's right
that's right shout out to everybody who
got it right yeah all right let's grab
some more super jets
Chris scan uh
Scana pieko probably pronouncing that
wrong I don't feel bad dude was awful
even before his stroke
you know
someone can be bad someone could be
nasty but I just I I gotta tell you man
Karma you don't wish that stuff on
people you know why because then Karma
finds a way yeah don't you'll come out
someone I'm telling you right now
there's a lot of people watch this show
and I don't know who it's gonna be but
someone's gonna be sitting there
laughing and mocking him and just
ragging on them and making fun of them
and then an hour later they're gonna
collapse and their family's gonna scream
and they're gonna have a stroke and
they're gonna be sitting in a wheelchair
being like now I understand that's the
way the universe works sometimes yeah
I've noticed that black magic it's
untargetable like you just say I want
that ill for a person and then it just
illness creeps into your reality I think
white magic works the same way when you
want healing for someone that the
Universe tends to heal you as a result
as well I don't know about all that I I
get it but you know what I think is
I've seen a lot of stuff in my life that
I would say defies probability or at
least what we think is probability which
either means within my limited human
confines we're predisposed to believe in
something greater than us or it means
based on our basic understandings of
probability and arithmetic there are
things that sometimes seemingly defy
that and we want to believe in something
greater she's quantum entanglement it's
scientific fact at this point
objects can entangle within reality and
they start to interact like in this
similarly vibrate together but it but
it's one object yeah what may be
happening is that when when electrons
are entangled is that you know you you
you you infuse energy on one and it
moves and then you know hundreds of
miles away another one's moving but it
may be because it's actually the same
object through multiple Dimensions or
something like that but I'm just saying
this throughout my life there have been
moments where I've been like watching a
video and I'm like that guy's so dumb
and then like I high five my friend and
we make fun of a guy and then like a
week later they're like I want to
introduce my friend and I'm like it's
the guy and I'm like oh geez now I feel
bad and so I've learned at a young age
like I would I would rag on somebody
skating and then I would fall and be
like I'm never doing that again like I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna mind my karma
and just try and be nice learn that
lesson very young don't don't mock
people who are suffering which from from
the best for one reason because what
happens to you you're gonna wish for
sympathy as well it's so crazy that
there's that state of mind which I I
love I embody that and then there's war
where the goal is to destroy another
thing or person or Society it's
incredible that we live in that binary
Duality if it's only two I mean there's
more than that going on like
all right let's read this one we got
Artemisia says he legit said quote I
didn't read in the Statue of Liberty
uh-huh
he did yeah I think it was referring to
the plaque right oh yeah give me your
tired or huddled masses Ezra or whatever
yeah
okay happy guy says predict it says Oz
will win 69 percent
well there you go
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim nobody
high fives after insulting someone I
mean figuratively like not not literally
like I'm like hey look at that guy he's
dumb yeah hey I meant like we're like
watching a skate video and then we're
just like dude that guy's pants are so
dumb oh he's gonna eat it uh what a what
a dork and then you know later you fall
and get hurt and you're like I'm not
gonna rag on people I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna wish for only the best because
like you don't want you know Bad Karma
no yeah and at the very least bad things
happen to you you can be like well you
know I did my best right
all right this is a very important one
from Austin Carroll he says I'm pooping
right now
still still been going on for a while
did you leave that Super Chat have a
good poop yeah yeah that's right you
know you use a Squatty Potty all right
Austin s it says here in Minnesota the
governor didn't show up for a debate so
his Republican opponent had an
uninterrupted q a session Dems are
doomed what really just didn't show up
wow I know Carrie Lake did that
basically right she had like an empty
stage or something and then she just
answered questions wow that's great yeah
man she's phenomenal she's just always
on always on all right quick name a
Democrat a-lister
me I ALC I mean I don't even know that's
a good point yeah AOC Gavin Newsom I
don't know I don't think so I don't know
he's like he's beat here you know
Bernie Sanders uh yeah but Bernie
Sanders is like he's a retiree status
he's like 37 he's about to be a free
agent they're probably maybe won't get
drafted or get hired again I mean like
another becoming young star of high
Charisma no way no I agree no I know
like I'm naming people that they throw
out there but Bernie's too old terrible
he's not gonna he's he's very famous but
he's too old yeah Newsome is not an
a-lister no but name a republican
a-lister come on so easy there's like 10
of them Trump obvious gnome DeSantis
Carrie Lake doesn't carry like just
ridiculously obvious and then uh
yeah MTG Lauren bobert these are massive
personalities AOC I think is fair yeah
but the rest of the squad they've not
been particularly prominent and even AOC
hasn't really been particularly
prominent the Democrats are just
flopping around yeah it's brutal all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
on the uncensored show coming up for you
at 11 PM you don't want to miss a good
follow the show at Tim cast iron you can
follow me at timcast faster faster all
right
you want to shout anything out
uh you can go to my Twitter handle AR
cluster or uh my c3's website Personnel
policyops.org thank you for coming on
that was I mean the show really got
dominated by us just talking about the
debate but you know oh man that's so
depressing I wouldn't watch it otherwise
and when you turn it off the first time
I'm like thank goodness thank goodness
and then I know the second time I'm like
no yeah but but anyway if you're looking
for positive news uh check out my
YouTube channel uh youtube.com forward
slash we are changed today I covered the
very optimistic New York Supreme Court
case and decision that I think is
absolutely worth it we're going to talk
about that celebrating yes but you know
I also got a video that you know people
could watch you know afterwards and
potentially right now but also uh
usually I'm in the chat room all the
time and in the beginning of the shows I
usually ask the the audience members to
guess my shirt and if they guess it
right they get the shirt and 100 bucks
and I want to announce that ahead of
zeitgeist a user got it right so I'm
gonna be sending you the shirt so
congratulations I also have to announce
that this weekend we're going to be uh
officially putting together our timcast
membership giveaway a new car oh that's
right and uh uh one lucky member at
timcast.com has a chance to win a car
but uh you should wait for the for the
rules and the and the the video released
before making any assumptions about what
this really means I will just say we
gotta check the legalities to make sure
we can do it before we actually confirm
we're going to be doing anything because
it is not I think anybody who's watched
the members only show I'll mention it
actually I'll mention what our plan is
in the members only show but uh it's
gonna be funny it's a gag okay just want
to let you guys know we're doing a bit
uh thank you guys so much for coming and
Andrew thanks for uh experiencing the
shared trauma amongst the group thank
you so much for having me it has bonded
us and made us stronger and closer yes I
don't feel strong it was like battle
Yeah I think it takes a few days to set
in it's like after working out you feel
all ripped up and then you know it's
like PTSD you'll be stronger for it
flashbacks uh catch you guys later fall
median Crossing if you want to get in
touch I'll see you later and I'm
served.com you guys can follow me on
Instagram it's really going to play some
usually active I won't get a Twitter
until young Buys so
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out